when it comes to films and television
shows there's a lot riding on actors
preparedness for a production even if
all of the crew members show up primed
and ready to work everything can fall
apart if the cast doesn't quite have it
together these stars got creative and
engaged in some last-minute scrambling
to make up for the fact that they
weren't quite prepared for their roles
when they signed on big mamas coma in
1999 the world almost lost Martin
Lawrence when the actor collapsed and
fell into a coma outside of his LA home
due to severe heat related exhaustion
Lawrence's condition was so serious that
for several days he required a
ventilator just to breathe it all
happened largely because he chose to
workout while wearing a big plastic suit
in a hundred degree weather to try and
get in shape for Big Momma's House I
recommend do not run a plastic suit do
you not do that I know that luckily he
went on to make a full recovery but the
media criticized Lawrence's decision to
get in shape since he wouldn't have many
opportunities to show off his abs in
costume anyway but walking around in an
80-pound bodysuit still required some
fitness preparation even if Lawrence
took it too far
tuned out prior to physically appearing
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
vision Paul Bettany never bothered to
watch a single film in the Iron Man
franchise despite providing the vocals
for Jarvis the heroes trusty AI sidekick
is approaching even when he was
recording his lines as Jarvis vet knee
didn't even get a full version of the
script and had no context for the
dialogue pieces he read as Jarvis I
would I would turn up at the end of the
movie and and speak into a microphone
for two hours and they'd give me a big
whopping great bag of cash in I bet
knees indifference to the franchise was
such that he admitted to feeling like a
pirate when he took his money and often
had to tell fans he had no idea who the
character was when he was approached to
speak about what is now one of his most
famous roles liquid courage undressing
in front of one person is hard enough so
it's gotta be especially awkward for an
actor to strip on camera with a whole
crew watching from the wings for margot
robbie her breakout role in the wolf of
wallstreet called for her to be in the
buff quite a bit and she knew the shots
would be ruined if her nervousness came
through on camera with little time to
prepare herself for one scene of
dream exposure robbie decided to do what
a lot of people might do for a
confidence boost and pounded three shots
of tequila before stripping down and
nailing the scene in one take meanwhile
co-stars Leonardo DiCaprio and Jonah
Hill weren't very familiar with the
effects of most of the drugs they were
supposed to pretend to take on screen so
both had to be coached on how to act
convincingly hi in fact DiCaprio was so
unsure about how to act
he'd later admit that he'd spent hours
watching this YouTube video of a guide
drunkenly rolling around on the floor to
better shape his performance learning
the lingo when Jackie Chan first arrived
in the u.s. in the 1980s he was
reportedly unable to speak even basic
English and quickly set about teaching
himself how to communicate by absorbing
Western media
he came to America alone to immerse
himself in the english-speaking world
and learn the language that way although
Chan did pick up on English pretty well
over the years he still had trouble
reading scripts as late as the rush hour
series and had to learned the lines for
many of his western films phonetically
do you understand the words that are
coming out of my mouth sometimes crews
would take advantage of this and pick
Chan say swear words or things he didn't
mean just for laughs I'm into feet I
like the one with the horses what's that
mean why you teach me doing dialect most
of the actors in Game of Thrones have
accents based on where in the fictional
world of Westeros they hail from
relative to the geography of the UK for
example characters hailing from the
north have thick northern accents
whereas those from the South speak with
accents commonly found in the more
southerly parts of the UK production was
reportedly insistent that the actors
playing the sons of Ned Stark should
adopt Sean beans native Yorkshire accent
but cute Harrington had no idea that
this would be expected of him an
audition for the role of Jon Snow in his
native southern accent although he was
told he was a good match for the
character he still needed to speak more
like his on-screen dad before the camera
started rolling
so Harrington along with the rest of the
actors expected to portray Ned Stark's
sons had to rush to ready their new
dialects to match their daddy's
off-screen affectation getting ripped
upon being cast to play
infamous British criminal Charles
Bronson a man so dangerously violent and
superhumanly built he once punched clean
through bulletproof glass in a fit of
anger Tom Hardy met with the man himself
to see if he'd sign off his portrayal
Bronson was unimpressed with Hardy's
physique however and initially said no
hoping to change Bronson's mind hardy
started bulking up after their first
meeting consuming nothing but pizza ice
cream chicken and rice while exercising
as hard as he could
two weeks later he bulked up enough for
Bronson to realize he was committed to
physically portraying him the fact that
Hardy also brought Bronson a muffin and
some milkshakes also likely didn't hurt
along with giving the actor his blessing
Bronson also shaved off his mustache and
mailed it to Hardy hoping the makeup
department could figure out a way to
glue it to his face failing that Bronson
hoped Hardy could carry the clippings
around in his pocket is a good luck
charm it's unclear which option Hardy
chose thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]